Ben birazdan anlatacağım konu Aslında
yaşayanında çevresindekilerin de çok
konuşmak istemediği çekindiği kaçtığı
bir konu ama aslında Belki de tam çok
çok konuşulması gereken bir konu 2003
yılıydı ben 25 yaşındayım o sırada bir
piyasa araştırma firmasında proje
yöneticisi olarak Çalışıyordum ama bu
hayatın benim istediğim hayatı
olmadığını anlayabilmek için ne yazık ki
o iş yerinde çalışan seviye gelmem
gerekmişti o dönem bir karar aldım
Çocukluk Aşkım olan müziğin peşinden
gitmeyi istedim ve tüm kariyer
olasılıkları ma bir kenara itip konsol
okumaya başladım son senesinde 30
yaşında hamileydim Mevlithan iki ay
sonra oğlum dünyaya geldi
Ama bu benim hayatımın en büyük dönüm
noktalarından bir tanesi ydi annelik
içsel yolculuk kendine Yüzleşme
sürecinin başlangıcıydı ve gene bizim
için çok önemli olan üzücü bir olayı ya
doğumdan 10 gün sonra yaşadık ciddi bir
yangından son anda kaçırıldık Bütün
gazetelerin üçüncü sayfa beri olduk o
gece 6'ncı kattaki evimizin
penceresinden oğlum uzattığımda
itfaiyenin evde uzandığında ancak su
biliyordu ikimizin de elin titremesi o
gecenin en büyük mucizesi galiba hepimiz
kurtulduk Neyse ki bizden çıktık Sağ
Salim ama Pencereden ama eşyasız ve
yoluna yap bulabildiğim 3 numara bebek
bezi ile yenidoğanı mı Ben izleyip onu
bir yastık kılıfına sarıp uyuttum da o
gece hayatında bir şeylerin kalıcı
olarak değiştiğini hissettim yani bu çok
de
Ya aslında benim hayatımın en büyük
mucizelerinden biri oldu çünkü böyle
büyük bir şey yaşamasaydım Belki de
çelebi'ye başlama kararı hiç
alamayacaksınız aldım diyorum ama asla
uzun sürdü altı sene sürdü oğlum
ilkokula başlamıştı bende içimdeki
boşlukla Evde baş başa kalmaya
başlamıştım hayatımdaki şeyleri
değiştirmek istiyordum ama ne yapacağımı
nasıl bir adım atacağımı bilmiyorum ve
ve şey dedim kendime Ben her sordum
kendim halledebilirim getirdi güçlüyüm
galiba hepimiz kendimize zaman zaman bu
Yalın atıyoruz o zamanlar esas gücün
yardım isteyebilmek olduğunu henüz
öğrenmiştim Yani bu düşünceler ve
duygularla boğuşurken yeni bir şey
deneyim dedim meditasyona başladım
yapanlar bilir orada Kendinizden kaçmak
Peki yer olmuyor ve bu beni bireysel
terapi yolculuğu hazırladığı kendimi
ikna ettim yangında var ya çok büyük
Tamam var çalışacağım onu daha ilk
günlük seansı fark ettim ki Aslında
benim en az 10 tane daha
bu farklı tram var ama hepsi hayatımı
derinden etkilemiş yangında başladık
çalışmaya oradaki duygularıma
korkularıma yoğunlaştım da yaşadığım en
büyük korkunun oğlumun bensiz büyümesi
olduğunu fark ettim yani Dumandan
boğularak yaşamını kaybetmekten
korkmuşum ve bu korku beni hayatımın en
ağır en acı beğen karanlık travmasına
götürdü beş buçuk yaşında komşumuzun
oğlu tarafında maruz bırakıldım cinsel
istismara o dönem Tabi o yaşanmaz
niyetiyle onu bana kötü bir şey
yaptığını hemen anlamamıştım Çünkü bana
Beni çok sevdiğini ve birbirini seven
insanların böyle oyunlar oynadığını
söylüyordu Bugün canım çok yağmur o gün
O'nun bir oyun olmadığını anladım seni
Anneme şikayet edeceğim dedim herhangi
birisine söylersen seni öldürürüm dedim
bu galiba hayatımın öncesi kararını
verdim Şimdi ölümü göze alarak anneme
onun yaptıklarının bazılarını anlattım
bazılarını diyorum Çünkü öyle bir gömüp
unutmuşum ki aslında onları bundan altı
ay önce Yani yaklaşık beş sene terapi
gördükten sonra seans odasında
hatırladım anıların ayrıntılarını Ben
annemi anlattıktan Sonra apartmanda bir
kavga çıktığını Bizim oğlumuz öyle
şeyler yapmaz dediklerini Ben
hatırlıyorum ben aynı zamanda komşular
da onlara inanmışlar ve aile böyle
şeyler olmaz demişler yani inanamamış
zaman ne anlatınca beni öldüreceksin de
o kadar emindim ki yaklaşık 15-20 sene
süren gece kabusların başladı her gece
yorganın altında sadece burun deliği
bırakarak uyudum ve rüyalarımda siyah
bir dumanın beni kovaladığını ve benim
ona uçarak kaçtığını gördüm
O da gene therapy odasında fark ettim ki
o siyah duman belli istismarcı ve beni
öldürürsün diyor ondan sürekli kaçıyorum
ne kadar maaş takibi tarifi ikna eden
Tamam da tam Duman'dan boğulmak üzere
olduğu yangında ama Bundan yıllar sonra
iş Bunlar yıllar sonra yirmi İki
yaşındayken yüksek sans yapıyordum ve
tez danışmanım olmasını istemek için
gittiğim motorlarda değer verdiğim bir
profesörün tarafından da taciz edilince
hayatım yeniden darmaduman oldu yorgun
önemli bir hayat ders verdi bana kendisi
dedi ki ben ona öfkeyle neden diye
sorduğumda çok abartılı tepki verdiğini
İş hayatına başlayacağını böyle şeyleri
başıma Hep geleceğine alışmam
gerektiğini söyledi çok önemli dersima
Bu yoldan şikayet etmeye karar
verdiğinde o dönem çok güvendiğim iki
tane hocam benim az geçirdiler dediler
ki o Profesör ve onaylanır sana değil
Ben hem rezil olursun hem de yüksek
lisansın yanar ben çok pişman oldum bir
karar aldım onu şikayet etmedim yüksek
nasıl bitirdim ama Dükkanı bir daha
kullanmadım yani her iki olayda da hem
mağdur beğendim hem de sözüne inanılmaya
bilinçaltı değişik Karlar oluyor travma
yaşadığınızda da ve tacizinden önemli
sonuçlarından bir tanesi suçlu paketi
bırakması hayata ve herkese bu suçun
farklı yansımaları olabilir Ben de
kurtarıcı olmak yönünde oldu hayatım
boyunca herkese Herşeyden kurtarmaya
çalıştım onlar istemese bile ve
bilinçaltım demiş ki ilk olaydan sonra
eğer kadın gibi görünmez Sen başına bir
O gelmez teminen giyim makyaj gibi
konularda hep uzak durdum ve kilo almaya
başladım 23 yaşındaki olaydan sonra
bilinçaltım demiş ki demek7 kilo
almamışsın çok hızlı bir şekilde 30 kilo
daha aldım Sonuç ortada orucumu Evet
kurudu ama bir araç yok olmayabilirdi ve
bu aynı zamanda çift yönlü bir kalkan ve
benim yapabileceklerimiz önünde kendimi
ördüm duvarlardan birisi oldu görünür
olmak kaydı besleyen Tıp özgüvensizliği
mükemmeliyetçiyim suçlu hissetmem ve
utancım gibi kimilerine göre böyle derin
travmaları değişik çıkartıp tekrar
onları üzülmek anlamsız Ama şunu
farkında değiller ya hayatımızda
yolcularımıza Yüzleşme sekk
tamamlanamıyor Uzo boşluk bizi hep
yaşıyor bir hayat yaşıyoruz ama hep
kendimize eksik hissediyoruz Ben Tüm bu
anıların ortasındayken istismarla
mücadele ederken kafam
Allah kızıma hamile olduğumu öğrendim
Çok korktum bu korkuyla çalışmalarını
hızlandırdı iki katına çıkardım
seansları yani kızımın gelişi başka
dönüm noktası oldu hayatımın oğlumla
başladığım Yüzleşme yolculuğu kızımla
ilmek kazandı ben kurtarıcı durumdan
sıyrılmaya başladığımda acılarımla
yüzleştiğim de ve yaşadığım hiçbir
travmanın benim suçum olmadan da
gerçekten yürekten ikna olduğumda
önündeki duvarlar ve birlik olmaya
başladılar ve içinde ne varsa oluk oluk
dışarı Aktığını hissettim o dönem o
değişim enerjisiyle hayatta çok güzel
insanları çektim bana ilham olabilecek
insanları bir akşam hayali vurdu ama bir
türlü yapamadım şey yaptım çocuk kitabı
yazmaya başladım iki tane çocuk kitabı
yazdım çok mutlu oldum bundan bir süre
sonra da hayalini kurmadığım bir şey
yaptım ve bir şarkı yaptım
konservatuardan mezun olduktan sonra hep
minik
ne kaybederdim ama hiç bütün bir şarkıya
dönüştüren demiştim bir şarkı sözü
yazmamıştım o akşam güzel bir insan
ilham oldu ve dedim ki yaşamın en mekan
acıyı geldi öykülü bulmandır en macera
yorum içine doğru yaşanan aldık her olun
ayrı bir hikayesi var herkesin ayrı
Yolları her gün ayrı bir hikayesi var
sende bu seninkini ve bu şarkı Teşekkür
ederim çok şaşırdım Bu şarkı benden
nasıl çıktı diye düşündüm ve bir buçuk
ay içerisinde onlarca şarkı
ne yaptım tam sayılarla 12 24 o dönem 13
numaralı şarkım suçum yok Biraz sonra
kulübün izleyeceksiniz Tam da yaşadığım
cinsel istismarın benim suçum olmadığına
ikna olduğum gün ortaya çıktı ve aynı
gün beş yaşında bir kız çocuğunun
istismar Haberleri vardı Ben yıllarca bu
haberlerin hepsi de ağladım o gece
ağlayarak Bu şarkıyı mırıldandım o minik
kıza kendimi ve ihtiyaç duyan tüm
istismar mağdurlarına yaptım ve benim
çocukluğumu rüyalarını ve terapi
yolculuğu anlatan güzel bir klip yaptım
ona animasyon benim için muazzam bir
süreçti içimde ne varsa aktı hissettiğim
süreçte her şarkının bir hikayesi var
Hepsi beni en az 2 şarj artık iyi Çok
iyi geldi bana süreç peki Ben bütün
bunları neden anlattım Şu Çünkü
anlatabilme hala aslında iyileşmenin
doğal uzantısı
Ne yani şimdi saklamaya devam ediyorsam
anlatmıyorsam asla Tam da ilişki
sayılıyorum ve anlatabilmek yerleşme
yolu aynı zamanda içinizdeki akıtmanın
bir yolu ve Biz birbirimizin yaralarını
iyileşiyor Uz temas ediyoruz birbirimize
ve iyi oluyor çünkü biliyorum ki mesela
bir kitap okuyunca iyileşir İnsan bir
tablo gördüğünde ye şiir şarkı bazen tek
bir kelime bizi içe döndürür değer
benzer yaraları olan tek bi kişiye değer
bilsem Deniz Yıldızı hikayesi gibi ve
ona suçunun olmadığını ve yalnız
olmadığını hissettirebilir sembene için
harika olur bu zor Duygu anlatma
kararını vermek ve Burada anlatmakta
bayağı Zordu ama Hasan Hüseyin dediği
gibi acıları O da edinmek mümkün ve
galiba bunu duyma hepimizin ara sıra
ihtiyacı var bir istismar durumunda Bir
suçlu var Evet ama bu istismara uğrayan
taraf değil bunu da konuşulmasına hatta
bağırılması Hayır
bu ihtiyacımız var o yüzden siz de bunun
içindeki yaralara bunun çıkartın
yüzleşin onlarla iyileşin ayağa Kalkın
ve anlatın Çünkü bizim sizde suçunuz yok
ve yalnız değilsiniz ben bu konuşmamın
giriş cümlesine sesini duyayım diye
buradayım olmasına karar verdikten Kısa
bir süre sonra arşına bir paylaşım çıktı
sevgili Bahar erişim bir paylaşmayı bu
orada bir alıntı yapmıştım ama en sudan
Ben izle konuşma bu alıntıyla bitirmek
istiyorum bir kadın ne zaman kendi
sesini duyurmak için ayağa kalksam
planlanmamış bile olsa tüm kadınlar için
de ayağa kalkmıştır bir suçum yok
biliyorum ama geç oldu Örümcek çocuk yok
biliyorum ama geç oldu öğrenme
bir tane kola yüklüyoruz başka dönünce
hiç bakıyoruz dürüstçe aynı bir çocuğun
ne suçu olabilir Herkesi kendi gibi
[Müzik]
sanmaktan başka suçum yok ki
çok kırıldım Suçumu yok biliyorum ama
geç olur En çocuğu olur Her içinden
atıyor çocuğum kaç yıl içinde durur Here
de acı için kendi suçluyor suçun yok
benim suçum ne
bu Ama geç oldu öğrenmez
abone ol